In 2011, the United Nations declared that
access to the Internet is a basic human right.
By the time a glass of champagne goes flat,
two million bubbles will have popped.
The 'Heil Hitler' salute is legal in Switzerland
as long as it's an expression of personal
opinion.
An experiment showed that 6% of drivers will
deliberately swerve to kill animals.
Humans speak more languages than there are
species of mammals.
Plants can suffer from sexually transmitted
diseases.
Statistically, the more rivers an area has,
the more languages will evolve there.
If you put a can of Diet Coke in water, it
floats.
Regular Coca-Cola sinks.
Because regular Coke contains sugar which
is denser than the sweeteners found in Diet
Coke.
For the last five years, China has built a
new skyscraper every five days.
The sign for the female sex represents the
hand mirror of the Roman goddess Venus.
More wine is drunk per head in Vatican City
than any other country on Earth.
The inventor of roller skates first demonstrated
them by hurtling into a party while playing
the violin and crashing into a huge mirror.
Whale milk has the consistency of toothpaste.
Snake charming is illegal in India.
1 in 10 Americans think HTML is a sexually
transmitted disease.
There is enough concrete in the Hoover Dam
to build a road across the US from coast to
coast.